the area of science that first really
got me interested and inspired was
astronomy it was a topic that looked at
those really big questions and tried to
put sense to things like what is our
place in the universe and how does
everything fit together gazing up and
looking at the Stars and thinking about
those questions still inspires me I am
still really engaged with astronomy
through outreach and through other
things as well I would describe myself
as a space nerd I Drive a bike with
that's covered in NASA stickers and I
always go to a talk or a public lecture
by someone talking about a space I find
that it's one of those things that
really can sort of tie humanity together
that quest for spaceflight or to
understand that is something more than
just us on earth astronomy is also
really great for outreach which is
something that I also enjoy talking to
members of the community especially non
scientists about some of the cool ideas
behind astronomy and science in general
astronomy is a really great way to get
people engaged that might otherwise sort
of not be so enthused by other Sciences
I think everyone can find an
appreciation for ideas relating to space
it's something that inherently a lot of
people love when you talk to them about
it they often say yeah I I love space I
wish I knew more about it and it's a
really good place to start with engaging
with people however I'm not currently in
astronomy major although I used to be I
graduated with my major in physics and
maths and I thought I'd talk about why I
switched from the astronomy major which
I had in first year to what I'd consider
a bit more broad
the physics and the math major there are
a few reasons why I decided to switch
and one of them came about just through
experiencing what research was actually
like in astronomy I was really lucky to
have some research opportunities I did a
project where I was working on Cube sets
and which really small satellites that
go around the earth taking data and what
this particular was taking data off was
going to be images of galaxies and
looking at that really really faint
regions of galaxies to see what we could
find there however once you get really
into the essence of modern astronomy
research it's less about those broad
questions it's less about wondering
what's what's in the galaxies is what's
hiding in it's more computer science
data analysis image analysis it's really
working on a big pipeline because
astronomy deals with huge data sets they
have a lot of data so the research group
I was a part of although they were using
data from telescopes they were just in
the middle of Sydney so there were no
actually telescopes being used for a lot
of the research astronomy the data would
come from other people and remote
locations at the big telescopes who
would collect the data and send it back
to the research offices for processing
and there was a lot of processing to be
done and I think astronomy now really is
it's kind of an office job where you're
writing a lot of lines of code to
process this data and try to find
meaningful information out of huge
datasets it's not that dissimilar from a
lot of
modern sort of big data fields and in a
way actually being immersed in that
research environment kind of lost a
little bit of the magic for me I still
really enjoyed being there and doing
that work how cool was it to look at
pictures of galaxies that no one else
has ever seen before because there are
sort of millions of galaxies across the
images you're looking at of course some
of them are going to be unique however
when I experienced what it was like to
be in an experimental physics research
lab it kind of fit my personality and
what I enjoy a little bit better I had
discovered something that surprised me
and that was that I enjoyed being
hands-on in the lab I thought I would
always be a more theoretical person but
I actually enjoyed putting together
experiments and not knowing what my
results will be being surprised by the
things that I see and trying to figure
out either what's wrong or what to do
next or how to interpret surprising
results I sort of find that really a lot
more motivating I'm also sort of moving
around and the lab rather than just
writing code it's something that I have
found to enjoy a lot more and it's gonna
depend on your personality and what you
personally enjoy as well so that's one
of the reasons I'm going down more of a
physics road the other is that I feel
the physics major and also the math
major are a lot more broad than the
astronomy or astrophysics one I think
that
astronomy itself is built on a
foundation of maths and physics but in
doing the Astro major you kind of
restrict yourself almost to the physics
and the math that are relevant for
astronomy and you're not getting that
full foundational sort of coverage I
think that by doing the physics and the
math you learn all of that foundation
and then can take it and if you want to
apply it to astronomy later but then
that's not your only option you can also
apply it to in the other science or any
other field in general studying physics
as a major it says that you're good at
solving complex problems and that you
can research sort of these fundamental
ideas and applying that is quite easy to
almost any research field but also going
out and pitching yourself to an employer
or someone you want to work with it's I
think easier to show that you've done
physics and maths and have an
understanding of this than to try to
convince them that analyzing stars will
give you the same skillset that's
relevant to an industry job and it is in
most cases true that an astronomy major
yes you're dealing with these big data
sets and so you can apply that to
anything whether it's finance or any
kind of startup and it's true but it's
harder to make other people understand
that if you tell someone you studied
astronomy they kind of put you in this
basket of someone who just knows about
stars and kind of nothing else but if
you can tell an employer that you've
studied physics or maths instantly it
sets you up heads almost a more broad or
more well studied candidate whether
that's fear or not that's just the way
that I've sort
seen it what I think is good advice is
to at least at the start of your studies
or in your undergrad study quite broad
courses and give yourself that range of
understanding in a topic that you can
then build specific skills on to later
so in this case I think having the
physics and the maths and then later
maybe for masters or PhD building on
that with specific astronomy or
astrophysics knowledge through higher
research and that way you've sort of
started broaden and gone narrow but you
could have gone narrow and in any field
you could have studied the physics and
then gone into a smaller field of
physics and to experiment or to
theoretical or applied it to another
area all together so the research that
I'm currently doing is actually applying
physics to a biological application I'm
looking at how plant cells respond to
pressure and I haven't done any biology
at uni I haven't done any since high
school but I love biology and I'm really
happy that I'm able to now work at a
cutting edge of research and biology
having essentially bypassed having to
study it and do exams and the topic but
still being well educated enough to
understand the ideas that are relevant
to my project and my project is a
physics project so I think starting
broad like that and then specialising or
building on your skillset is a really
valuable thing to think about even if
you think you're sure you want to go
down a particular road at the start you
can definitely change your mind I know I
have throughout my studies if you have
the chance to do any sort of research
projects or internships along the way
while you're studying I would suggest
doing them in different different areas
as
possible so you could do one research in
astronomy and won an experimental on a
theoretical which is kind of what I have
done and then actually see which one you
enjoy because you might sort of be
surprised I know I was definitely
surprised by what I actually enjoyed
it's easy to make assumptions or what
you think a particular subject will be
like for research and then sort of have
an experience that doesn't quite meet
those assumptions that you made it's
hard to know truly what you'll enjoy
until you actually do it and are
immersed in that environment the three
really broad kind of pillars I see in
the physical sciences would be physics
maths and actually computer science and
I think if you have a stretch or a focus
on one of those areas then you can
pretty much do everything you can you
can go into any kind of field because
you'd have the ability to take problems
and break them down and to the exact
steps of how to solve a problem you'll
be able to deal with data you'll be able
to deal with gathering and interpreting
results and you'll be able to
communicate your results I think those
three subjects and a combination of them
really are a good basis for doing a lot
of things I think in each point along
the way if you're studying or trying to
pursue a certain subject just do it each
point what you enjoy so if that's
picking a research subject picking a
supervisor trying to decide the
direction of your research do what you
find to be interesting in the field or
interesting to you sort of at that
moment and don't worry too much about
how going down a road you you didn't
want to go down because you you might
actually enjoy it and you can
change you you don't have to box
yourself into anything too soon or at
any point all of these subjects that
I've spoken about are more similar than
they may seem on the surface they share
a lot of common ideas and skills and if
you can do one and you want to do
something else you can change and apply
those skills because they're all sort of
working towards a common purpose they're
all driven by that curiosity and
imagination to try and solve and figure
out the world around us whether that's
in the stars or in an experimental lab
they're all pretty similar